um yesterday i posted on twitter um the bosses
of itv are coming in what would you like me to
ask them i could various suggestions some
serious some less so but i thought this one
was very interesting from um somebody called
henry warren um and he says this could you
please ask them why they're not turning on
the subtitles by default on children's tv
it's been shown to double literacy uh youtube
which you mentioned in caroline already
do it um kids do youtube kids do it and the bbc
are also now embracing this why i apologize for
my cat's tail why and why are you not doing
this by default....
Rocco, put your tail down.
ninety percent of them fci tv that's a
guaranteed ninety percent of uh citv conspiracy
i just can i just say i just do that to
your publishing people appearing before
us it's particularly effective with captain
ministers very awesome i'll have another game